ich habe mir immer gewünscht und
vorgenommen meine staatspolitischen und
parteipolitischen ämter in würde zu
tragen und ziehe eines tages auch in
würde zu verlassen
zugleich weiß ich dass so etwas in einer
politischen ordnung nicht gleichsam am
reißbrett geplant werden kann sondern
dass das nur in einer fortwährenden
persönlichen abwägung von freiheit und
verantwortung wie auch in enger
abstimmung mit meiner partei und
zwischen den koalitionspartnern einer
bundesregierung zu geschehen hat
denn welche entscheidung auch immer in
welche richtung getroffen wird hat ja
das wissen sie alle tief greifende
auswirkungen das muss nach bestem wissen
und gewissen abgewogen und bedacht
werden und das habe ich getan und das
werde ich auch täglich weiter tun
welchen beitrag kann ich also persönlich
in der jetzigen situation leisten für
unser land und für meine partei
ich bin seit nunmehr über 18 jahren
vorsitzende der cdu deutschlands
eine aufgabe die ich mit leidenschaft
und hingabe versuche auszufüllen und
seit fast genau 13 jahren bin ich
bundeskanzlerin der bundesrepublik
deutschland ein amt das auszufüllen eine
tägliche ehre und herausforderung ist
als sie am 30
mai 2005 von dieser stelle aus meine
erste kanzlerkandidatur öffentlich
bekannt gegeben habe habe ich sie unter
anderem damit begründet dass sich
deutschland dienen möchte deutschland
und den menschen zu dienen das ist eine
in zeiten wie diesen zumal national wie
international sehr herausfordernde aber
auch erfüllende aufgabe und dass ich das
nicht schon so lange tun darf dafür bin
ich sehr dankbar
ich habe einmal gesagt ich wurde nicht
als kanzlerin geboren und das habe ich
auch nie vergessen zugleich habe ich das
sichere gefühl dass es heute an der zeit
ist ein neues kapitel aufzuschlagen wenn
wir alle stehen in der zeit und für mich
ist es heute an der zeit in folgende
entscheidung mitzuteilen erster
auf dem nächsten bundesparteitag der cdu
im dezember in hamburg werde ich nicht
wieder für das amt der vorsitzenden der
cdu deutschlands kandidieren
zweiter diese vierte amtszeit ist meine
letzte als bundeskanzlerin der
bundesrepublik deutschland bei der
bundestagswahl 2021 werde ich nicht
wieder als kanzlerkandidatin der union
antreten und auch nicht mehr für den
deutschen bundestag kandidieren und das
will ich nur zu protokoll geben auch
keine weiteren politischen ämter
anstrengen